Nate Burleson NFL Network analyst you
can see him on Good Morning
football Mondays through Fridays 7:00
a.m. Eastern NFL Network provides
exclusive coverage of the 2018 NFL
Scouting Combine through March 5th
starting at 9:00 a.m. Eastern also he's
got a rap video that we played a little
bit of and I'm gonna bring it back
because I think it's really good here
ecaps the NFL season from 2017 Nate good
morning can you help us with this the
acting the actress who is the Russell
Wilson of the acting world you were
thinking I was thinking the same day as
did they lose in traumatic fashion but
it was described as the nonsense off the
field distract from the owner field
talents but nonsense not as been
scandalous are bad but more pointing the
spotlight this is a tough one
a baby won Academy Award when asked her
I'm so on the blank here but I'm very
curious
I wanted up was married to a very famous
musician Gwyneth Paltrow that is good
Wow is there another one on there that I
can we can test Nate on I did like the
the Matt Ryan one is is is that Amy
Adams yeah Amy Adams yeah similar you
know what else do we have Ben
Roethlisberger is who Polly Francis
McDormand Tom Brady and Meryl Streep and
we can see of course right what else any
any other ones that we can test Nate on
yes bone Carson Wentz is compared to a
young rising star who's there's no
stopping them in the acting world not
necessarily Academy Award winner Carson
Wentz cuz compared to this actress whom
I'm also has a lot of physical skills
Emma Stone Emma Stone no okay Margot
Robbie Margot Robbie
oh yeah I like that okay we're talking
Suicide Squad huh what about drew Brees
do we have so who would be the acting
equivalent of Drew Brees among actresses
the description is Nader well done there
you get a free t-shirt okay
Cam Newton okay now don't tell me don't
don't tell me Dennis
give me the description the description
we're just gonna say I would still go
out there throw Halle Berry out there
with the description is Newton greatness
with a vibrant off-field personality
still young mmm that doesn't help Halle
Berry's older yeah Oh still young
yeah I love movies and I love acting and
actress world give me a hint here
she's a noted Archer Oh
jennife Jade law right Jennifer Lawrence
Jennifer Lawrence Jennifer Lawrence and
Cam Newton silver linings playbook
got a little spice to them sometimes
misunderstood I like how you're breaking
this down Nate all right a couple of
things to get to as a former wide
receiver when you hear that the NFL is
going to redress the catch rule you know
what do you what do you make of it first
of all that here we are again and there
all of a sudden try to redefine what a
catch is and what is not a catch
clapping vigorously and that that's me
it's applauding the lead for trying to
correct something you know we've been
talking about this for I don't know how
long
started off then we're in Chicago
traditional game Calvin Johnson tweets
the ball on the final drone somewhat of
a Hail Mary but we're we're in position
to win and I look at him goes down and
get the knee a hairpin it's one arm down
I'm thinking as the rulebook state
that's in this for to success with all
the body parts they hit the glass okay
this is how start speaking off with us
say no no no wait a minute we got to
look at that again and according to the
rules that is not a kid she did not
survive the ground and blame long day
but it's deflating to lose like that so
I've always been bitter about it and you
know you thought fourth that's Brian
lastly Jesse James I mean it's too many
situations where we're penalizing guys
for trying to make a great place and
that's not what the Swedish about to
sweep the ball highlight and then
knowing that highlight is going to make
my top five top ten over the weekend not
oh man that was a great play Tibet I'll
never see it again because it's not
going to exist after this afternoon's
match and you know we were spoiled in
the sense that we watch all these other
sports hits and it bounces off the wall
and we think oh that's amazing that
counts it's on top a guy takes off on a
step in front of the free-throw line and
it skims the rim you don't see the rest
saying well it didn't survive the net or
the rest or it doesn't count if football
is getting back to the basics which
means you catch the ball it's secured
one hand or two hands you get two feet
down and those baubles and all popping
out falls that's perfectly fine with me
but to say it's not a catch it's
basically you know pissing on us and
paying us ran I mean we all know this
for the couple we go back to us plan at
the park and it's sitting there catching
the ball and that's what it should be
now well we still have the conversation
catches this season that will inhabit
scratching head of course but I don't
think there will be as much confusion
goes through yeah and we're talking to
Nate Burleson the NFL Network analyst
former wide receiver in the NFL I I just
it penalized is somebody who's athletic
you make an athletic move the
did Bill Belichick is so far ahead of
everybody else in the NFL telling his
wide receivers when you catch the ball
just catch the ball don't try to make an
athletic move because he doesn't want to
have didn't want to have any of these
scenarios
give me the wrapper that you want to be
compared to what would be the biggest
compliment the biggest compliment of
course is jay-z's he's one of the best
of all time he he paints a picture and
tells a story and that's basically well
I'm an 80s baby I feel like he was the
80s manatees and I love hip-hop in a
sense that it was created to tell a
story I'm not a huge fan of some of
these new artists because even though
the beat is nice I have no idea what
they're saying so if I can't make out
what the hell you're talking about and I
really don't want to listen to it so
that's what I wanted to do I wanted to
come in and write something so I'll put
together two verses the NFL Network and
the NFL they got behind it Chapas video
in New York over the course of three
days you know it's fun this is young
generations of fans and athletes love
music and pop coaching I left the game
right around that time where that's part
of who I am too so what I throw on TV is
try to bring a blend that honors the
traditional nature of being an analyst
which gives everybody a chance to learn
the sport from my experiences and how I
break down Exynos but also it's the kids
that go to school with my 13 year old
and 11 year old and say man well I love
the fact that your dad can put together
a song and a rap that gives me the
feeling that football is going to be
back in a few months I put out a rap
album I think 2003-2004 okay okay that
was a DPL right well I it was called Dan
Patrick sings the rap hit it was just
covers is what it was and it was it was
more of a like a lounge singer singing
than I got yeah so it was a smoking
jacket and cigar kind of Straight Outta
Compton mother named so you see like
that's the edited version there there's
the explicit one too yeah
remixed and we both here and in Wyoming
and you know risk the generations you
know I'm saying I'm a little Eponine
type reaction up/down got the background
dancers I'd be more than happy if you
want to collaborate and listen and if
you don't know now you know I'm gonna
I'm gonna have I'll supply the
mercedes-benz okay and then after that
and I bring the dance with me get Peter
Schrager in there I mean we're Trager
can dance a little bit right oh yeah
shredder
did you ever see the video of him
dancing with charissa Thompson at the
Super Bowl on the sidelines you got to
bring it up oh my goodness that that
should lead the show tomorrow
good morning football should lead with
that tomorrow and then when he's dancing
with no Carissa can dance the Shriya
this reg inator cannot yes this is very
very much true this my guy I love him to
death struggles with the movements yeah
you know you remember Jerome with Morris
Day Mike Dec Schrager is like triggers
Jerome with Morris day ok ok so I got
you yeah he's he's he's that one I got
yeah but you have to you have to google
that and it's him and Kristin Thompson
on the sidelines during the Super Bowl
halftime show oh boy it's good stuff
it's always good to talk to you Nate
thanks and love the video it's available
on at NFL Network
Twitter at NFL Network with nature rap
video good to talk to you again Nate
thank you yeah I appreciate it man it's
gonna be a lot of stuff going on over
the next football in sports is enjoy
basketball - so bring me in whenever you
want we'll sit down - do it again
I love it alright for more Dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]